If you ask someone to, like, picture the deadliest psychiatric disorder on earth,
they might guess schizophrenia.
Right. Or maybe severe depression. That's usually where people's minds go.
Exactly. But the reality is that the highest mortality rate in all of psychiatry belongs to
a condition that, well, it often just starts as a diet. We are talking about eating disorders.
Yeah. And for a long time, the cultural conversation around these conditions has
treated them as just one big blurry monolith, you know?
Oh, 100 percent. People often default to this completely inaccurate idea that they are all
just extreme vanity or, I don't know, bad eating habits or a generalized desire to be thin.
But today, we are tearing that assumption down.
We really are.
Welcome to today's Deep Dive. We are looking at a landscape of human suffering that is wrapped up
in behavior, biology, and culture. But we actually have a map to navigate at this time.
And it's a very specific map.
It is. We got our hands on this dense clinical prep guide from a medical resource called
Pass Ready Prep. And this is the literal study material used to train medical professionals
on how to categorize and treat these disorders.
But our mission today isn't to cram for a medical board exam.
Right. No exams here. We want to use this clinical framework as sort of a decoder ring
for human behavior to strip away the psychiatric jargon so you, the listener, can truly
understand how the human brain breaks down in these scenarios and crucially, how it heals.
What's fascinating here is how this clinical framework
proves that eating disorders are highly specific systemic medical conditions.
The guide argues that you don't just look at a messy list of symptoms.
Right.
You look for three specific separators that carry this entire category of disorders.
Three pillars that basically define the boundaries between these conditions.
And those are weight, compensation, and body image.
Weight, compensation, and body image.
Exactly. By drawing these precise lines, the medical community is acknowledging that these
aren't just variations of the exact same problem. They are distinct illnesses with distinct
biological mechanisms requiring completely different life-saving interventions.
Okay. Let's unpack this because I absolutely love how beautifully structured this approach
is for learning. It gives us a really clear lens to look through.
It really does. It takes the guesswork out of it.
Right. Instead of guessing,
you use these three separators as a compass to figure out exactly what is happening to a patient.
So let's use that compass right now and look at the first separator, which focuses entirely on weight.
Which brings us to anorexia nervosa.
Yes, anorexia nervosa, code F50.0 in the manual.
And the prep guide defines it with just striking precision.
It says, it is the restriction of intake leading to a significantly low body weight
accompanied by an intense fear of gaining weight and a disturbed experience of one's own body.
The really key thing to notice there is that the very first requirement in that
clinical definition is entirely physical.
Right. The restriction leading to low weight.
Yes. Restriction of intake leading to a significantly low body weight.
That is the defining separator. I mean, you have the intense fear
and the disturbed experience of the body. The psychological component, sure.
But the clinical anchor that sets anorexia apart from other conditions
is the significantly low weight.
Because the body is literally consuming itself at that point.
Exactly. The starvation literally degrades the heart muscle.
It shuts down organ systems. It strips the bone density.
So the psychiatric condition drives the behavior,
but the behavior produces an acute physiological crisis.
See, I'm struggling to square this a bit. Because if this is a psychiatric disorder,
you know, a disease of the mind categorized in the same manual as anxiety or PTSD,
why are we treating it like a physical trauma ward?
That's a really common quote.
Like the guide dictates that medical stabilization and weight restoration
must happen before anything else. But shouldn't doctors be starting with therapy
to fix the root cause, the trauma or the cognitive distortion,
rather than just forcing calories into the body?
Well, the harsh reality is that you cannot do cognitive therapy
on someone whose brain doesn't have the basic caloric energy to process a thought.
Oh, wow.
Yeah. I mean, the human brain consumes about 20% of the body's energy.
In a state of severe malnutrition, the brain literally shrinks.
The gray matter decreases.
Wait, really? The brain actually physically shrinks.
It does. The neural pathways that govern logic,
emotional regulation, and even self-reflection are physically compromised.
So if a psychiatrist tries to do complex behavioral therapy
with a patient in the depths of anorexia, it's just not going to work.
The patient's brain fundamentally lacks the neurotransmitters
and the glucose required to engage in that work.
That makes so much sense.
The physical body has to be saved and restocked with fuel
before the mind can even begin to heal.
And speaking of restocking fuel, the guide actually
gives a massive warning to clinicians about that exact phase.
It highlights this phenomenon called refeeding syndrome.
Yes, which is incredibly dangerous.
It was terrifying to read about. It's like,
think of a massive power grid that has been running
on dangerously low voltage for months.
If you suddenly flip a switch and surge a million volts back
into those compromised lines, the transformers
don't just turn on, they blow up.
That's a perfect analogy.
Like an engine that's been starved of oil.
You can't just floor the gas pedal immediately.
You have to ease the system back to life
where it completely seizes up.
Why exactly does a psychiatric disorder have
the highest medical mortality rate when it comes to this?
Because of the electrolytes.
When you introduce carbohydrates to a starving body,
it triggers a sudden spike in insulin.
And that insulin surge pulls massive amounts of electrolytes
like phosphorus, potassium, and magnesium
out of the bloodstream and into the cells
to metabolize the glucose.
But because the patient's overall stores of these electrolytes
are already depleted from the long-term starvation,
pulling them out of the blood drops the serum levels
to critical life-threatening lows.
And the heart runs on those electrolytes, right?
Exactly.
Those specific electrolytes govern
the electrical pulses of the heart muscle.
So that sudden drop causes catastrophic cardiac arrhythmias.
The heart simply stops.
And that is the physical mechanism behind why a psychiatric illness
carries such a massive, immediate medical mortality rate.
Which perfectly explains why the treatment pathways
outlined next are so specialized.
The guide notes that once that delicate medical stabilization
is finally achieved, the psychological treatment
actually diverges based on the patient's age.
Yes, it branches out.
Like, for adolescents, the gold standard is family-based treatment.
But for adults, it is enhanced cognitive behavioral therapy,
or CBT. Why the split?
Well, family-based treatment, or FBT,
is a brilliant approach for a developing brain.
It doesn't just mean, you know,
eating dinner together as a family.
Oh, it's much more intense than that.
It essentially enlists the parents or guardians
to act as an external auxiliary brain for the teenager.
An auxiliary brain? Wow!
Because the adolescent's own neural pathways
are so hijacked by the eating disorder.
Making decisions about food is completely paralyzing.
So, the family takes over the feeding process entirely.
They temporarily remove the burden of choice from the child
until their brain recovers enough to rationalize again.
And then for adults?
Meanwhile, enhanced CBT for adults
focuses on giving the individual the tools
to restructure their own deeply ingrained
cognitive distortions around shape and weight.
But remember, the foundational anchor for both of these,
the separator that dictates this entire life-or-death protocol,
is the significantly low weight.
Right. The low weight is the trigger for all of this.
So, if medical stabilization is how you save
the visibly starving patient,
what do doctors do when a patient's heart
is failing from an eating disorder,
but they look like they are at a perfectly healthy weight?
That changes the entire clinical picture.
We have to shift our entire focus from weight to behavior.
And that brings us to the second clinical separator
in our framework, compensation.
This is where we encounter bulimia nervosa,
which is code F50.2.
The guide defines the cycle of bulimia
as recurrent binge eating,
followed immediately by compensatory behaviors.
And those behaviors can vary widely.
Right. The source lists them as self-induced vomiting,
the use of laxatives, extreme fasting, or excessive exercise.
And for a clinical diagnosis,
this cycle has to happen at least once a week for three months.
And just like anorexia,
the patient's self-worth is entirely tethered
to their body shape.
But the crucial clinical contrast
that professionals use to navigate this, the separator,
is that people suffering from bulimia
are typically at a normal weight,
or even above normal weight.
Right.
The presence of the binge compensation cycle,
combined with the fact that the patient is not underweight,
is exactly what pulls this away from an anorexia diagnosis.
Here's where it gets really interesting,
at least to me, looking at this from the outside.
That specific clinical separator
completely shatters the societal assumption
about what an eating disorder, quote unquote, looks like.
Oh, complete.
If you ask the average person on the street
to picture someone with an eating disorder,
they always picture the severely emaciated patient.
But the guide is telling us that with bulimia,
the person might look completely average to the outside world.
They're blending into society perfectly,
while internally they are trapped
in a violent, exhausting cycle.
It makes it an incredibly isolating disease.
I mean, the suffering is entirely hidden in plain sight.
And the medical dangers are just as severe,
but the mechanisms of death are different.
Different how?
Well, the source warns clinicians
that the physical toll of these compensatory behaviors
is catastrophic.
Purging, whether through vomiting or laxatives,
violently expels essential fluids and minerals from the body.
There goes the potassium again.
Exactly.
You are continuously draining the body's electrical system,
specifically the potassium.
When potassium levels swing wildly from purging,
you are at an extreme risk of sudden cardiac arrest,
regardless of your body weight.
So you're dealing with a fully fueled brain,
but a continuously short-circuiting heart.
That is exactly what's happening.
The treatment protocol, the guide list for bulimia,
starts with enhanced CBT,
which makes sense to address those cognitive distortions.
But the pharmacological intervention
really stood out to me.
It's highly specific.
It notes the use of fluoxetine,
pointing out that it is the only antidepressant FDA
approved specifically for bulimia.
Fluoxetine is a Selective Serotonin Reuptake Inhibitor,
or SSRI.
And to understand why it works,
you really have to look at the neurobiology
of the binge purge cycle.
Okay, let's look at it.
Purging isn't just about getting rid of calories.
The physical act of purging triggers a massive release
of endorphins and dopamine in the brain.
It actually functions as a profound,
albeit destructive, emotional release valve.
Oh, wow.
So it's chemically soothing.
Yes.
The patient essentially becomes chemically addicted
to the soothing neurochemical rush of the purge itself,
just to manage their distress.
And that's where the medication comes in.
Right.
Fluoxetine steps in to increase the availability
of serotonin in the brain,
which stabilizes the underlying mood and impulse control.
It raises the baseline of emotional regulation,
making the patient way less reliant
on the chemical spike of the purge
to cope with their distress.
So we have weight separating anorexia
from bulimia,
and we have compensation defining the cycle of bulimia.
But let's change the variables again.
What if a person is consumed by binging,
but we completely remove the compensation
half of that equation?
Okay.
Like what if they binge,
but they never purge, they never fast,
or run 10 miles afterward?
Well, that shifts the clinical picture entirely
to the third major condition in the guide,
which is binge eating disorder.
Code F50.81.
Yes.
It is defined as recurrent binge eating,
accompanied by a profound sense of loss of control
and marked intense distress.
And like bulimia,
this has to occur at least weekly for three months.
But the guide hammers home the main point
with absolute certainty.
There are NO compensatory behaviors.
That absence of compensation
is the whole defining separator from bulimia.
Right.
The individual experiences the overwhelming compulsion,
the complete loss of control during the binge,
but the cycle just stops there.
They endure the intense psychological pain,
the shame, and the physical discomfort of the binge
without utilizing any physical mechanism to undo it.
Which must be incredibly distressing.
It is.
And because the behavior is different,
the underlying neurobiologies is different.
Research actually suggests that binge eating disorder
is often linked to a deficit in dopamine receptors.
Oh really?
Yeah.
The brain just isn't getting enough natural reward signals
from everyday life,
so it seeks out massive quantities of highly palatable food
to basically force a dopamine spike.
That makes perfect sense.
And the treatment protocol reflects that difference beautifully.
The guide states the first line psychological treatments
are enhanced CBT or interpersonal therapy.
But the approved medication option
listed for binge eating disorder
is a drug called listex amphetamine.
Now I looked this.
A listex amphetamine is a central nervous system stimulant.
It is often used to treat ADHD.
We just talked about using an SSRI antidepressant
for bulimia to stabilize mood,
but here we are using a literal stimulant
for binge eating.
Because a stimulant targets the exact dopamine deficit
we just discussed.
By stimulating the central nervous system,
listex amphetamine increases the availability
of dopamine and norepinephrine in the brain's synapses.
So it's feeding the brain what it's looking for.
Exactly.
It basically wakes up the prefrontal cortex,
the part of the brain responsible for executive function
and impulse control.
When the brain has a steady adequate supply of dopamine
from the medication, the overwhelming impulsive drive
to seek out a massive food reward is dramatically reduced.
To me, this just proves the absolute necessity
of accurate clinical diagnosis.
Without a doubt.
I mean, if you have someone who is binging
and you don't take the time to use this framework
to figure out if they are compensating or not,
the results could be disastrous.
Oh, completely.
If you misdiagnose bulimia as binge eating disorder
and you hand a central nervous system stimulant
to a patient who is actively purging,
you might severely spike their anxiety,
increase their heart rate,
and actually accelerate the compulsion to purge.
Wow.
Treating the wrong disorder with the wrong med
just wouldn't work.
Precision medicine really requires precise categorization.
It does.
The clinical lines drawn by these separators
dictate the chemical and psychological tools you use
to literally save someone's life.
Okay.
So we've covered weight, we've covered compensation,
but earlier we talked about a third separator, body image.
Yes, the third pillar.
Right.
Up until now, anorexia, bulimia, and binge eating disorder
all feature this massive overwhelming distress
about body shape, weight, or an intense fear of fatness.
The patient's self-worth is entirely tethered
to their physical form,
but what if an eating disorder has absolutely nothing
to do with body image?
Which brings us to the fourth diagnosis in this prep guide,
Avoidant Restrictive Food Intake Disorder,
commonly known as ARFID.
Code F50.82.
The guide defines ARFID as food avoidance or restriction
that leads to significant nutritional deficiency,
weight loss, or dependence on supplemental feeding.
Now, on the surface,
if a patient walks into a clinic severely underweight
because they are avoiding food,
it sounds exactly like anorexia.
Right.
Physically, the presentation can be identical.
The malnutrition can be just as severe,
but the psychological engine driving the starvation
is fundamentally different.
And the prep guide explicitly states this separator.
The restriction in ARFID is not driven by body image
or a fear of gaining weight.
There is zero body image disturbance whatsoever.
None.
So what actually drives someone to stop eating
to the point of clinical malnutrition,
if not a desire to be thin?
The guide identifies three specific drivers for ARFID.
First, it can be entirely about
the sensory qualities of the food.
Like the texture.
Yeah, the texture, the smell, the temperature,
or even just the look of the food
is so overwhelming to the nervous system
that the brain registers it as intolerable.
Okay, what's the second driver?
Second, it can be driven by an intense fear
of an aversive consequence.
Meaning, the person is terrified that if they swallow,
they will choke or they will vomit.
Oh, wow. And the third.
Third, it can simply be a profoundly low interest
in eating altogether.
The fundamental biological drive for hunger
just isn't registering in the brain.
The guide also notes that ARFID
is seen very frequently in children, right?
Yes, very often.
Imagine a child who experienced
a traumatic choking incident.
Their developing brain creates
a massive hardwired association
between the act of eating and mortal danger.
They aren't avoiding food
because they want to fit into a smaller clothing sign.
Right, obviously not.
Their nervous system is screaming at them
that the act of swallowing
is a literal threat to their survival.
So what does this all mean?
When I read this section,
I realized ARFID sounds far more
like a specific severe phobia
than what culture traditionally
calls an eating disorder.
That's a very accurate way to look at it.
It's like being terrified
of getting trapped in a building's elevator
rather than hating the architecture
of the building itself.
The restriction is a desperate safety mechanism
against choking or sensory overload,
not a weight control tactic.
Exactly. The avoidance is a protective instinct
that has just gone into pathological overdrive.
And because the driver of the disease
is a phobia or a sensory processing issue,
the treatment diverges completely
from the other disorders we've discussed.
How so?
The guide states that the first line treatment
for ARFID is nutritional rehabilitation
combined with behavioral and family work.
You do not use enhanced CBT
to challenge their beliefs about their body weight.
Because they already know
their body weight isn't the problem.
Precisely.
Instead, clinicians use exposure
and behavioral therapies
to slowly, safely desensitize the nervous system
to the sensory experience of food.
It is entirely about retraining
the brain's threat response.
Like, a therapist might spend weeks
just having a patient sit in the same room
as a certain food.
Then touching it.
Then smelling it.
Slowly proving to the amygdala
that the texture or the act of swallowing
will not result in death.
It's slow, methodical work.
Well, we've covered a tremendous amount of ground today
pulling apart this framework.
Let's lock this in
so you listening to this
can take this clinical map with you.
Okay, so we have three core separators
that define the major eating disorders.
First is weight.
The presence of significantly low weight
is the clinical anchor
that separates anorexia from bulimia.
Got it.
Second is compensation.
The presence or absence
of commensatory behaviors
like purging or extreme fasting
separates bulimia from binge eating disorder.
And the third.
Third is body image.
The complete absence of body image fears
or fat phobia separates ARFID
from anorexia.
By looking for the low weight,
identifying the compensatory behaviors
and assessing the body image drivers,
clinicians can cut through the behavioral chaos.
They can pinpoint exactly what neural pathways
and physiological crises they're dealing with.
It brings order to what looks like chaos.
And for you listening to this,
why is keeping this medical framework in mind
so valuable?
Because understanding
these exact clinical separators
helps you cut through the cultural noise.
It destroys the stereotype
that eating disorders all look a certain way
or that they are merely an expression
of extreme vanity.
Which is so important.
It allows you to view
these incredibly complex agonizing conditions
through a lens that is medically accurate
and deeply empathetic.
When you know the actual mechanisms
of the suffering,
whether it's a heart failing
from a lack of electrolytes,
a brain lacking the glucose to think
or nervous system terrified of swallowing,
you can better understand
the immense reality
of the people enduring it.
It permanently shifts your perspective
from casual judgment
to genuine clinical understanding.
Absolutely.
But before we wrap up today's deep dive,
I want to leave you
with a final thought to ponder.
Something that builds
right out of the source material
and the treatment protocols
we just analyzed.
We noted earlier
that when treating
the exact same condition,
anorexia adolescents respond best
to family-based treatment.
Right, where the family steps in
as the executive function.
Exactly.
Meanwhile, adults respond best
to enhanced CBT,
where the individual is taught
to tackle their own internal
cognitive distortions independently.
The clinical pathways
to rewiring the brain diverge
based entirely on the age
and developmental stage of the patient.
Which raises a truly fascinating
question to explore on your own.
How much does our age
and the immediate structure
of our social environment
dictate not just how
a psychiatric disorder
takes root in our minds,
but which specific social
or cognitive therapies
actually possess the power
to rewrite our neural pathways
and heal us?